[Música]
bolivia elige a su presidente en una
repetición de los comicios casi un año
después de una anulación que llevó a la
renuncia y exilio de evo morales- ahora
desde que abran las urnas el órgano
electoral anunció que no usará el
sistema de conteo preliminar y habrá que
esperar a los resultados oficiales que
podrían tardar varios días tenemos
reportes
chile conmemora este domingo el primer
aniversario de las protestas masivas
contra las desigualdades en el país con
el recuerdo de 31 fallecidos y múltiples
violaciones a los derechos humanos la
ciudadanía espera un referendo para
cambiar la constitución mientras siguen
impunes la mayoría de crímenes cometidos
por los carabineros
y francia- guardar el luto por samuel
patxi el maestro asesinado en un acto de
terrorismo islamista hoy continúan los
homenajes y el ministro de educación
prometió que francia protegerá a quienes
se dedican a la enseñanza para ti fue
decapitado luego de mostrar caricaturas
del profeta mahoma en una clase de
libertad de expresión
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información lo más importante de
américa latina y del mundo iniciamos en
américa latina' porque hoy france24
cubre la repetición de las elecciones
generales de bolivia que originalmente
se celebraron en octubre de 2019 y que
tras las denuncias de fraude en el
conteo de votos que hoy siguen en
investigación llevaron a la salida de
evo morales- presionado por el ejército
y tras casi 14 años en el poder hoy la
fiesta electoral se celebra por fin tras
sufrir varios aplazamientos a causa de
la pandemia y con cinco nuevos
candidatos sin embargo el favorito es
luís arse del partido socialista más de
morales seguido por el ex presidente
centrista carlos meza además habrá un
cambio de estructural en el proceso
anoche del órgano electoral anunció que
esta vez no habrá conteo preliminar para
evitar generar incertidumbre entre la
población en un clima de alta
polarización según el tribunal
más temprano conversamos con nuestra
corresponsal mary vaca quien nos explicó
las razones de esta decisión
hola que tal el presidente del tribunal
supremo electoral salvador romero ha
explicado que se va a privilegiar la
certeza frente a la rapidez esto
significa que el tribunal electoral va a
ser un conteo de rápidos un conteo de
votos oficial y que va a descartar el
conteo rápido que estaba previsto para
el domingo por otro lado esto significa
que los ciudadanos bolivianos no van a
poder conocer el mismo domingo de parte
del tribunal supremo electoral quien ha
ganado las elecciones y que van a tener
que esperar tal vez varios días a
conocer el conteo oficial según la ley
boliviana se puede esperar hasta siete
días que los tribunales electorales
departamentales cuenten los votos 1 a 1
sin embargo lo que sí se va a conocer el
domingo es el conteo de los medios de
comunicación existe una tradición en
bolivia de que los medios y algunas
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
contratan sus propios conteos rápidos y
sus bocas de urna y los pueden dar a
conocer a partir de las 8 de la noche y
entonces los candidatos suelen también
tomar una posición respecto
a las elecciones y los resultados en
base a los datos que dan los medios de
comunicación en lo político se han
generado varias repercusiones por
ejemplo el ex presidente evo morales
desde argentina que es el jefe de
campaña del movimiento al socialismo ha
señalado que es altamente preocupante
que se haya tomado esta decisión y el
duda de las verdaderas intenciones y el
partido creemos que está tercero en las
encuestas ha pedido al tribunal
electoral reconsiderar esta decisión
porque considera que vulnera el
principio de la transparencia y la
publicidad de los datos
en cambio comunidad ciudadana ha
aceptado la decisión del tribunal
supremo electoral aunque ha lamentado
que esto haya sucedido de esa manera por
su parte la comunidad internacional que
está observando estos este proceso
electoral ha aceptado también y ha
entendido la decisión tomada por el
tribunal electoral a último momento
y espere esta noche a las 7 pm ahora
bogotá quito lima el especial
informativo de france 24 en directo con
el seguimiento a las selecciones de
bolivia presenta a liliana valència
en otros temas hoy se cumple un año del
estallido social en chile que dejó al
menos de 31 fallecidos más de 3000
heridos con arma de fuego y hubo graves
violaciones a los derechos humanos entre
ellas torturas disparos a víctimas de
trauma ocular violaciones y abusos
sexuales también vejaciones y otros las
causas judiciales en el país para
perseguir a los agentes del estado
culpables de estos hechos apenas han
avanzado para el análisis está con
nosotros marco moreno director de la
escuela de gobierno de la universidad
central de chile señor moreno gracias
por estar con nosotros bienvenido y un
año después cuáles son las ganancias de
las protestas
fundamentalmente creo yo que un año
después lo que vamos a tener la
posibilidad a los chilenos y chilenas
exactamente en siete días más es un
referéndum para para cambiar la
constitución no creo que el principal
hecho quisiera recordar en la historia
justamente que esto se ha dirigido con
ese efecto la posibilidad de encausar
esa energía a través de un proceso de
cambio constitucional que comenzará el
próximo 25 del público del plebiscito
que está convocado para preguntarle a
los chiles medicina si quieren
cambiarnos su constitución bueno pero
entretanto qué es lo que pasa con la
impunidad a menos del 1 por ciento de
los carabineros que estuvieron
involucrados en hechos de violación a
los derechos humanos en las protestas
han sido traídos a la justicia porque ha
sido tan lento el gobierno chileno en
este tema
lo que pasa que el movimiento social
iniciado no estudie el año pasado
recordemos que tuvo un quiebre
importante provocado por la pandemia
entre marzo y agosto prácticamente que
fueron el periodo más complejo a la
bandera aquí en chile no hubo una
especie de cápsula miento por lo tanto
no se pudo avanzar porque la prioridad
está está en otros temas es a partir de
septiembre comienzan a reactivarse todas
estas investigaciones y están siguiendo
el curso que tiene la justicia chilena
esperamos pronto del resultado
especialmente en el caso de díaz
vibraciones contratada a los derechos
humanos los daños oculares que se
produjeron en muchas víctimas y personas
activamente murieron como consecuencia
de este estallido social
una de las denuncias que realizan los
activistas es que faltó muchísimo más
control gubernamental y que si piñera
hubiera tenido en cinta a las fuerzas
del orden pues no se hubieran dado estas
violaciones masivas porque no fueron ni
uno ni dos los casos sino muchísimos
usted qué opina
bueno hay una crisis profunda de la
policía de carabineros como se llama en
chile xy segaría con el con el estallido
social recordemos que la policía está
sometida al poder civil depende del
ministerio del interior y había allí no
solamente en este gobierno sino tienes
de retorno a la democracia una falta de
efectividad de control por parte de citi
a las policías creo que sí es un tema
que está hoy día también la discusión
bajo el mar parte
seguramente el proceso de cambio la
construcción pero está en marcha un
proceso de reforma a la policía
carabinero como consecuencia de la
situación extra grande que se producción
a los derechos humanos a partir del
estallido social pues muchas gracias a
ustedes por sus opiniones y continuamos
con más noticias en argentina este
sábado fue el día de la lealtad cientos
de ciudadanos salieron a las calles de
buenos aires en el marco del festejo por
el día de la lealtad peronista el
presidente alberto fernández encabezó la
celebración en movilizaciones en su
defensa cuando el país se vive una
profundización de su crisis económica
por la pandemia este día conmemora la
masiva movilización obrera que el 17 de
octubre de 1945 llenó buenos aires para
reclamar la liberación de juan domingo
perón a quien luego sería elegido
presidente del país tres veces
en eeuu el presidente de donald trump
dijo que la victoria de joe biden en
elecciones el próximo 3 de noviembre
sería un paso para lo que llamó la
izquierda radical demócrata robert
realizó dos mítines en los estados clave
de michigan y wisconsin a 17 días de la
votación en la que espera ser reelegido
advirtió que byd en acabará con la
historia del país en la campaña de biden
se emitió un comunicado que criticó al
mandatario por celebrar un mitin en
wisconsin en medio de uno de los peores
repuntes de la crisis sanitaria este
domingo la cita será en nevada para
trump y en carolina del norte para joe
biden
y en noticias de francia para hoy se
esperan movilizaciones en varias
ciudades en defensa de la enseñanza
laica y en memoria de samuel para ti
el maestro asesinado tras enseñar
caricaturas de mahoma en una clase de
libertad de expresión el ministro de
educación de jean-michel blanquea
prometió que el estado protegerá a los
docentes
cientos de flores en la entrada de la
escuela y carteles en homenaje al
profesor de historia y geografía
asesinado vecinos padres y alumnos
rindieron homenaje a samuel para ti
remy de 11 años cuenta que su clase de
sexto grado fue la última en tener
contacto con él
estaba un poco en shock con lo que dicen
en la televisión no me lo esperaba en
absoluto salí de la escuela y diez
minutos después murió
los que recuerdan a patti hablan de una
persona buena y cariñosa el maestro de
47 años y padre de familia era un hombre
tranquilo apasionado por su trabajo y
sin antecedentes según quienes lo
conocieron
era un hombre discreto por lo que nunca
hubo controversia sobre él
en la ciudad de jaén decenas de
profesores también rindieron homenaje
gracias a una movilización organizada en
línea
la investigación del servicio nacional
antiterrorista entregó los primeros
elementos la identidad del atacante fue
confirmada se trata de un joven de 18
años nacido en moscú y de origen
checheno los servicios de inteligencia
no lo conocían por radicalización pero
sí por pequeños delitos por los que
nunca fue condenado el hombre había
obtenido un permiso de residencia de
diez años y poseía el estatus de
refugiado en francia uruguay network
jefe inmediatamente después de los
hechos se publicó un mensaje de reclamo
en una cuenta de twitter llamada a
lanzar chiche n270 acompañado de una
macabra foto de la víctima futura que
abolió la víctima hasta ahora 11
personas han sido detenidas entre ellas
familiares del agresor y padres de
alumnos del colegio de confianza antonio
niño
francia lucha para frenar la propagación
de coronavirus la semana pasada del
presidente francés emmanuel macro 1
ordenó que la gente se quede en casa a
partir de las 9 de la noche en las
ciudades más afectadas afirmó que el
virus se estaba propagando en fiestas y
reuniones privadas
no hubo fiesta para los parisinos las
calles y las terrazas de parís y de
otras ocho ciudades de francia quedaron
vacías a tempranas horas del sábado
antes de empezar el toque de queda de
las nueve de la noche a las seis de la
mañana a las nueve en punto y nos vamos
a casa es la hora a la que salíamos
normalmente así que es un poco extraño y
ha de ser tan lindo
para vick ciertas líneas de metro se van
a llenar completamente de gente a estas
horas y tal vez nos olvidamos del
distanciamiento social en el metro donde
los dueños de restaurantes advirtieron
también sobre el impacto de la medida en
un sector que ya sufrió grandes pérdidas
durante el confinamiento de primavera
nadie come a las seis de la tarde en
francia eso no existe tal vez algunos
turistas pero como los turistas no
pueden viajar con más de 32.000 nuevos
casos el sábado francia batió un nuevo
récord de contagios confirmados en 24
horas y las autoridades han identificado
las interacciones sociales entre los
jóvenes como una fuente del repunte pero
ellos rechazan ser señalados como
responsables si no
si hablamos de responsabilidad colectiva
hay que mirar la capacidad de
anticipación del gobierno y en esto
deben ser cuestionados pero no creo que
los jóvenes tengan la culpa de la
renovada propagación de la pandemia como
estudiantes cuando tenemos pequeños
trabajos como niñera o trabajar en
parque de diversiones no sabemos si
podemos obtener una extensión de toque
de queda y nosotros dependemos de estos
pequeños trabajos para pagar el alquiler
y la comida el gobierno defiende los
toques de queda como única medida para
evitar un nuevo confinamiento nacional
en momentos en los que europa comienza a
hacer frente a una segunda y más severa
ola de contagios al menos de azerbaiyán
declararon un nuevo alto el fuego en su
conflicto por nagorno karabaj que entró
en vigor a la medianoche sin embargo
apenas horas después armenio acusó a
azerbaiyán de violar lo pactado las
partes ya se habían acusado de violar
otra tregua la semana pasada
puede que los civiles de nagorno karabaj
y azerbaiyán tengan al fin un pequeño
respiro luego de que las autoridades
armenias y azeríes acordarán un cese al
fuego humanitario que inició a
medianoche del domingo
'francia que ayudó a mediar celebró la
tregua advirtiendo que el cese el fuego
debe ser respetado de manera estricta
por ambas partes estaremos muy atentos a
eso y seguiremos comprometidos con
asegurar que las posibilidades se hacen
de forma duradera y que negociaciones
creíbles puedan dar inicio rápidamente
la región separatista de nagorno karabaj
está habitada mayormente por armenios y
desde el 27 de septiembre ha sido el
escenario de fuertes choques en los que
cientos de personas han muerto el cese
del fuego llega luego de que un ataque
con misiles en la ciudad a serie de
ganja avivar a la violencia dejando
docenas de muertos y heridos incluidos
niños ahora ellos deben y serán
considerados responsables de este crimen
nos vengaremos en el campo de batalla
los separatistas armenios aseguran que
fue una respuesta a los ataques del
ejército de azerbaiyán en la ciudad más
grande de nagorno karabaj y en otros
lugares de esta disputada región mixto
cómo puede la comunidad internacional
ser tan indiferente con la gente este
pan aquel
este es el segundo intento de tregua que
se produce luego de otro alto el fuego
por el que medio rusia y fue violado a
las pocas horas los enfrentamientos son
los peores que vive en la región desde
1994 cuando una tregua acabó con la
guerra entre ambas partes hasta aquí el
informativo sigue en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com feliz domingo
[Música]